de manière générale je trouve qu'on est
dans une époque qui est un peu dur avec
la notion d' addiction il me sortir un
vent de santé un peu à la californienne
qui s'est abattue sur nous ces 10-15
dernières années on s'est tous dit
qu'ils allaient tous qu'on soit souple
qu'on se met au sport qu'on fasse du
yoga qu'on me dit qu'on arrête le café
qu'on fasse gaffe avec l'alcool qu'on
fasse gaffe avec la clope et pas le
sucre et palau gras et paloma chaque
phase des câlins aux arbitres fassent
attention aux écrans et berlin sur le
fond sur le principe je comprends
évidemment très belle impulsion
esprit-saint corps sain tout ça est
magnifique
je ne sais pas si on a choisi le
meilleur moment de l'histoire de
l'humanité pour se défaire de tous les
plaisirs chimiques qui rendait le monde
supportable dans le sens où je veux rien
vous spoiler parce que vous avez l'air
innocent mais le monde est en flammes
grosso modo on est dans la merde
jusqu'au cou est ce que c'est vraiment
maintenant qu'on veut se mettre à
produire des vieux en méga forme super
fit complètement sort jusqu'à 103 ans en
pleine conscience pour tout bien voir se
péter la gueule
alors que financièrement on va avoir un
problème de soutien des retraites tu dis
est ce qu a pas un truc à jouer tu vois
ce que je veux dire à partir de 65 ans
tu légaliser drogues dures
tu fédérer ce parti pour les retraités
ils partent dans une dernière grosse
montée mdma cocaïne le coeur lâche tu
vois c'est plus sympa pour eux c'est
plus sain pour les finances publiques
moi je propose je ne suis que solution
voilà jeu
évidemment je ne fais pas l'apologie des
addictions il y en avait beaucoup plus
graves que d'autres my mind qui brise le
coeur en ce moment c'est l'addiction aux
sports parce que je perds des proches
mais des gens que j'aime et des gens je
respectais des autres invités à mon
anniversaire que je perds de vue au
moins de trois mois est que je retrouve
au détour d'une balade sur instagram en
train de prendre des photos de leur
propre ventre
n'avait pas la réaction adaptée à cette
année c'est dire qu'on est arrivé à ce
moment-là de raffinement civilisationnel
et technologiques de notre histoire il
ya cinquante ans on vient on aura les
bagnoles qu'il aura plus personne ne
râle cancer non on a des produits qu'ils
mettent leur dossier instagram c'est
très triste
et je ne parle pas d'une photo prise par
un tiers jeudi pathé à la plage avec des
potes on prend une photo était un peu
botte du couple les autres mutations
s'aggrave on a tous fait un faux bouffer
sait faire ployer pas tout si je peux
pas te
parle de gens qui pour la photo
eux-mêmes sévèrement des sas et des gens
ils sont chez eux comme ça ils sont là
non mais le monde doit savoir
prennent leur téléphone ils vont
chercher la bonne lumière chez eux déjà
le niveau de tristesse quand même faut
dire les choses dues à des gaz et écoles
sans trouver qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
contractent tout seul la traite la
solitudine i saw iv a
pris possession instagram à cuntis le
gange en open au game
no pen s'était déjà un slogan parfait je
ne sais pas pourquoi on a voulu rajouter
des saints à patins mais souvent je me
rends compte que je ne m'explique pas le
comportement des sportifs jusqu'à ce que
je me rappelle qu il sont drogués et là
tout à coup tout fait sens parce que le
sport est une addiction c'est un fait un
meuble et sportif le 10 lancers n'a
existé une addiction socialement
acceptable non c'est cool mais c'est
vrai qu'ils se comportent comme des
toxicos ils sont d'épisodes et
comportement de john keats electric 1
quant à des potes qui disent des trucs
genre [ __ ] l'autre chose c'est chez
moi dimanche 22h30 pas motivé il
pleuvait jeter en pyjama et touche même
si rien ne bouge le cul j'ai eu mes
baskets je suis rico à 22 km tu dis mais
ça devrait pour un gramme de coke c'est
pas normal en fait
les coureurs en particulier peut on les
a vraiment perdu et les jantes sont du
running on les a perdus c'est terminé
ils sont plus avec nous parce que tu
mélanges une addiction avec en plus un
encouragement de tout le monde autour de
toi parce que personne aime courir donc
les gens qui courent non seulement eux
ils sont en train de se doper en plus
tout le monde autour leurs déchets pas
comment tu fais tellement courageux
c'est magnifique du coup ça les lances
de délire christique et c'est pour ça
qu'ils finissent les marathons comme ça
parce que dans leur tête je pense
vraiment il ya l'abbé pierre et e juste
au dessus qu'ils y mettent cette seconde
au kilomètre maman on les a non perdu du
poids
conclue avec nous de terminer la preuve
c'est que il ne se cache plus qu pour
courir alors que pendant longtemps tu
vois la course à pied c'était comme les
changistes puis voix c'était un truc que
tu faisais dans les bois ou dans des
salles spécialisées c'était cool mais tu
étais avec la communauté tu vois ce que
je veux dire mais maintenant ils courent
en ville mais la ville n'est pas fait
pour courir tu le vois bien ils sont les
savent pas quoi faire ils vont en avant
en arrière ils font des tours sur
eux-mêmes et savent pas quoi faire au
feu rouge on dirait des hirondelles
pendant une éclipse enfin c'est tragique
[Applaudissements]
et surtout nous tous citoyens marchands
ou les gènes
c'est à dire que quand tu te vois c'est
pas qu'ils font le tour où ils te disent
excusez-moi truc quand tu les gets
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils font des
petits bruits de carling de punk comme
ça dans ton dos récurrents
donc il ya des moments tu es en vie
c'est bien sapés tu vas un rendez-vous
de boulot tu te sens femme des années 80
rien ne peut arrêter et tout à contre tu
faut que tu te pousse pour laisser
passer un gars qui va très vite nulle
part qu'à son stade